pretty cool thing I want to ask you
about is the uh everyday calendar that
you worked on
that was a long time that took a long
time yeah so basically I I designed this
calendar like I wanted to start
meditating every day
but it's really hard to meditate every
day and to like kind of build that habit
and what I would do is I would make
these grids in my notebooks where I
could like check a box for every day
like I just wanted like a little ding I
did it and like this thing of
accountability
but then I was like this is I don't want
to have a notebook that I do this in
like I want an art piece that I can hang
on my wall like accountability art and I
made uh this thing called the everyday
calendar which has an entire year on it
so it's 365 days and if you tap any of
the days you light it up and we turn it
into a Kickstarter campaign and it's not
a product that I'm selling my through my
product business the extra door what's
it called the yacht store yeah and uh
that for people who are confused is the
right way to pronounce your last name
which does it it's right but it's so
wrong
it makes my last name is spelled
g-i-e-r-t-z who does that song uh If
Loving You Is Wrong I Don't Want to Be
Right yeah
there's no singing in my last name yet
that's what that's what makes it because
uh what's his name uh uh the the from
the office he covers it
um from the British office which is the
better office
okay uh tangent upon a tangent upon
tangent so you said you created the
everyday calendar to make a more
beautiful in quotes and more sacred gold
star system on a wall not a notebook
that gets thrown into a drawer yeah wow
well said past me
you uh you said that making this
calendar taught you a lot in quotes I
feel like a like a real investigative
journalist uh
you've said in 2018 yeah I'm waiting for
the gotcha can you share some of the
lessons you've learned like what do you
mean you've you've learned a lot from
making this calendar what are we talking
about as somebody who builds things
manufacturing something is such an
unrelated process like making one of
something and making ten thousands of
something like they're not even distant
cousins like it's completely different
beasts to tackle and
um yeah so that was one of it everything
takes so much longer than you think it's
going to I did a Kickstarter campaign
that we launched in 2018
after my surgery and
yeah it's just you know you think you're
so generous with the timelines we still
ended up being a year late but we
shipped
we're good
um but yeah I mean I'm trying to get my
product business off the ground we
launched in May
and it's just yeah it's just a pain that
somebody's terrified of disappointing
people I'm like why have I chosen some
of the jobs where it's the easiest to
disappoint people you can disappoint
people at scale no yeah I can disappoint
people at scale and also them actually
haven't paid me money to deliver on
something which is a terrible
transaction but it's I'm just stoked to
realize that I love the job still like I
love the product development aspect of
it I love trying to design stuff for
manufacturing and figure it out and like
anticipate how people are gonna use your
products and like the everyday calendar
I mean we've sold thousands of them now
they're all over the world and it's like
people actually finding something useful
that I made and implementing them into
their lives it's just
mind-boggling especially because this is
tracking habits good habits so they're
bad ones you can do it forever
you use it however you want I went in a
drinking binge again today yes
kicked another kid
what does it take to a mass manufacture
something what did you learn about that
like what are can you like
elucidate the gap between the one the
Prototype versus the the product
development for Mass manufacture I mean
for one of it is yeah the manufacturing
the tooling that they use in
manufacturing and to do things in a
cost-effective way is really different
like I can make a one-off man it's going
to take me 17 hours but obviously you
can't spend 17 hours per calendar when
you're doing something in Factory
um
I think it's that like quality control
is such a beast you cannot trust anybody
telling you that things are going to be
okay like you're you have to have such
trust issues and it's also terrifying I
mean as somebody who's doing everything
independently I haven't raced any
capital for it like it's all
self-invested and we're doing it all
in-house
it's just you know yeah I could buy
10 000 calendars but then what if all of
them are have a manufacturing issue or
you know it's just
it's just terrifying because the risks
are so high but also I got to this point
where for one this is something that I
wanted to do for a long time but
something that going through health
problems taught me
is how fragile my business model is
because I mean I'm basically running an
influencer business where
I make videos on YouTube and then I have
an ad spot and I talk about a brand so
like I'm a human billboard which is fine
it grants me a lot of freedom to play
around
um but if I am not well enough to be on
a stage giving talks or be in front of a
camera everything stops like it's such a
pillar of a business and it can topple
over at any given moment or like YouTube
could change your algorithm like
legislation could catch up and change
how you're able to advertise on the
internet like it's so frail and I really
felt like I need to diversify what I'm
doing and also just to keep it
interesting for myself
so what I decided was to start a product
business because also it's kind of this
perfect combination of businesses where
I can turn my YouTube channel into an r
d Department because I have a reason to
constantly be exploring things and
churning out new products
I can also do that as early audience
testing and see what people are actually
excited about and if there's something
that I think would make an interesting
product I can pass that over to the
product business and then once I'm ready
to Market that and sell it I can pass it
over to the YouTube channel so it's like
I can kind of
once I realized that YouTube didn't feel
like an end goal for me
I was like okay then I can use it as a
tool to accomplish these other things
that I want to do and this was one of
them so yeah it's a lot that went into
it and one of the tools like it says r d
but it's also kind of advertisement for
the cool stuff that you're doing I think
I think Mr Beast is one of the creators
that's also starting to understand this
power of this uh reputation that you've
built
of like people trust you like they love
you
to do cool stuff they trust that you put
your heart and soul into a thing yeah so
like and they feel your pain and the
struggle too you know like if a product
like for example say the everyday
calendar like there was issues in
manufacturing something like this but it
was hot yeah it would feel the pain of
that and it was still support I mean
that that's the beauty of it when you
have the actual person right there
struggling with their with their lows
and highs that's a decision that I made
really early on where I was like the yet
store is supported by me but it's
separate from me it's not merchandise
you don't have to know who I am or care
about who I am to be interested in this
product and if you go on the website
uh like you have to go to the about page
to find anything about me like it's
definitely not like this is the most
brand and I think anybody who's followed
me for a long time will see that like my
personality is sprinkled into it but
it's still like clean off of me and I
think that's also because I wanted
something that was separate from me
because I
I'm also running out of narcissism
believe it or not I'm like I don't feel
like I wanna I don't want it to be about
me
and I want it to be something that can
also run independently of me and doesn't
like I want to be able to retire my face
and still do like the other stuff
because I think it's fun but I don't
want that to be the core of it what
other kind of stuff uh have you worked
on for the product design
uh yeah for for you so I mean a lot of
the products I decided to launch the
store with a really small roster or
products because developing products is
such a it's it's such upfront heavy like
cost wise and just investment such a
it's very big upfront investment so and
I know that it would take a while or I
knew it would take a while for me to
kind of find the right tonality and
visual language for the brand so I just
wanted to launch it have it be out there
start working on it start like learning
more about what it entails uh even if we
just had a small roster product so we've
released it with we have a puzzle
yes this is the web uh but I wanted to
release a puzzle that has one piece
missing so it's actually as far as I can
tell it's the world's first officially
incomplete puzzle you get 499 out of 500
a pieces I keep the 500th piece so I
have a box
in my workshop with everybody's missing
pieces yeah and I don't know what to do
with it yet but someday it will come to
me profound artistic statement it is
something uh it's definitely something
and I I'm surprised by how many of them
we've sold which I'm also like I kind of
wanted to have that product product out
there because I was like can you imagine
having a pitch deck if I do ever raise
money of being like
you know how good I am at selling things
I sold people 5 000 incomplete pencils
also have
no it's like a lot of the products I
call them basket fillers like they're
kind of just like stuff where I'm like
yeah this is like easy to throw into
your basket I mean we have these rings
I'm wearing them so there's a
screwdriver ring which is a Phillips
head screwdriver and then a screw ring
that kind of has a recess like a
Phillips head screw have these sawdust
socks that make you look like your feet
are covered in sawdust like you spent
all time in the all day in the shop
without having to put any of the actual
effort in but then
we have four more products on the
pipeline that we're working on and that
are kind of the more the the big
ambitious
products that are more in line with what
I want the brand to be like the tagline
is unique solutions to Everyday problems
and it's just a lot of like trying to
develop novel takes on existing products
so something where the function becomes
a bigger bigger part of the design yeah
so what's the process of creating
something like that like the even the
everyday calendar so like what what are
some challenges that are interesting
along the way so you have to sketch it
out you have to like brainstorm and draw
things out and then create a schematic
and see like how how do you know what
it's going to look like visually don't
yeah and it's I mean I so the everyday
calendar the first so I just built it
for myself first like that did not come
as a as a product idea first and that's
kind of been the process that I've had
for a lot of things like I make it for
myself and then I'm like oh maybe other
people would find this useful too so the
everyday calendar the first prototype I
made
it had actually physical mechanical
toggle switches so 365 toggle switches
that you could flip so if you worked out
that day or meditated for me was
meditating
um you can just flip that switch and
that was great but when I started
evaluating it as a product it's
if you have 365 of something in a
product like The Runaway cost is crazy
so the cheapest option most reliable
option we could find was capacitive
touch so basically it's a touch
interface and the front plate is the
circuit board itself so it's this like
the circus board
um that's designed in this really
fancy way so it looks like a
a beautiful piece of art not to take my
own horn too much uh but it's actually a
circuit board
um which I also thought was really
interesting of like using this that
people usually hide away in in products
and it felt like a nod to my career in
electronics as well being like no let's
make it pretty let's make it put it
front and forward
um
but yeah I mean what I'm realizing now
more and more is like there's so many of
like I would love to turn the puzzle
table into a product
but then it's like that would be a seven
thousand dollar table and I don't want
to sell a table for seven thousand
dollars so you're kind of limited to the
price bracket you're in and it's like
your margins are tough like maintaining
your margins are really really tough and
as somebody who's like I would love to
sell the stuff that we're doing cheaper
but you just it's just not feasible like
you need those marches to survive and
well one of the the genius things in the
conversations I've had with Elon is the
ability through sort of systematic
questioning of how things have been done
in the past to discuss what is the
lowest cost way to solve a problem
and so he's very good at getting to like
with Optimus robot for example the
humanoid robot how do you get the cost
down yeah
yeah and that seems to be like one of
the essential things to do
in um in any product that you have to
mass manufacture is constantly discussed
like how do we simplify simplify it's
definitely a design limitation that's
interesting it's both hard and
interesting to work within and that's
such a different thing as well it's like
as I talked about before like what is
the context and what you're creating
things like I'm still building things
I'm still inventing things but I changed
the contacts and it has a very different
set of limitations and constantly trying
to simplify your product to make it
cheaper and yeah it's a really
interesting and different type of design
process you can lose some of the magic
though right like
people can do that a little bit too much
I think apple is famous like Johnny Ive
is famous for
sort of focusing on design first and not
worrying about the cost later because
you don't want to sacrifice there's some
stuff that's gonna cost more but it
keeps yeah some of the magic
I think is for some of the products that
we're working on it's like I'm like
let's just make it the best we think it
can be and then we can scale back from
there like just like let's not impose
these limitations on ourselves up front
like let's just make it the most
beautiful version of itself and then we
can decide what we want to compromise
with or compromise on yeah that's what I
say every day when I look in the mirror
it's beautiful and then we can
compromise yeah
put on that suit yeah yeah and see how
goes wrong later